i want to understand the the culture a
little bit better because if you're not
around it you don't get it you don't get
why people in the military love 2a so
much right what the brotherhood is what
the pat always talks about the
camaraderie so i mean you're hiring
veterans you're around these people
you're empowering these people
what what i understand is what is it
like why does the military obviously
are as proponents of the second
amendment why what is it about the
military that people just don't
understand the brotherhood of the
military well a lot a lot of uh
most people that i that were war
fighters in in infantry special
operations tend to be proponents of the
second amendment because when you're
deployed like black rifle coffee black
rifle that's a life-saving equipment
that's life-saving tool
everywhere you go i slept with that
thing i went to ciao with it you know
that is the difference between
saving my own life and my teammate's
life and not being very proficient with
it and it's a tool
and a lot of this like the civilian side
that's never touched a gun right you're
scared of what you don't know but that's
what we did we hand it every day we know
how to safe handle it and um i mean i
carry a gun every single day in texas
because i mean
if something happens and and not to get
too far into it but like when people oh
more guns uh we'll fix the gun problem
we just saw it happen in indiana when an
active shooter shot i think two or three
people and a concealed carry license
holder shot the guy and saved countless
lives so for me that's the whole reason
it's a it's a tool and it's a tool of
safety and
that comes from i think a lot of us just
carrying those in in our background but
yeah to the culture side of the military
man it was just
we lived in a tent together for like
months upon months and so you just kind
of have this bond that never changes i
had
the the opportunity to see my two best
friends i've known for 18 years um went
to basic training airborne
rip um ranger school war um so we gotta
drink whiskey and tell war stories this
weekend so that's cool it's it's i
haven't talked to them in months and we
just pick it up right where we left off
and something like that i'm very blessed
to be a part of in your videos um
because it's not all glory it's not all
glorified i mean in your videos some of
your best friends are in your videos
half of them have freaking no legs bro
or missing an arm like i'm like holy
[ __ ] this guy's doing comedy he's doing
satire he's being funny but at the same
time just looking at the images guys are
missing limbs how do you grapple with
the the humor of life but also some of
the
the downs of being in the military
i can't speak for you know
all amputees or anybody i'm not an
amputee so i can't say anything but i
will say like most of my friends who are
missing limbs they want to be treated
like they're human
and i think a lot of times with visible
war injuries people treat them
differently and they just want to be a
part of the crew and that's why you see
a lot of um the jokes that we make where
i think crispy uh omar avila he he rolls
the uh the lawnmower and pretends to
chop his leg off and then you know stuff
like that so it's it's kind of humor
through horror kind of vibe where we
just have to laugh about it because you
can't change what happened you can only
change what hopefully will happen do
these guys have regrets missing limbs or
they do they wish they never went to the
military did they double down and say it
was the best decision of my life i'm
trying to understand the mindset
especially when you lose limbs for your
country i would i would say that we're
we should be very thankful that such men
and women exist that can lose limbs and
say i'm happy and i would do it over in
a
heartbeat
one of my mentors clint trial um
absolute badass dude um over 20 years in
the military last deployment got both
his legs blown off and um he works with
us now and he's been like a mentor and i
sit down and talk this guy i just want
to go like do push you know swing a
kettlebell because his perspective on
life through all the tragedy that he's
had is just absolutely brilliant and i
wish more people would sit down over a
cup of coffee and listen to a gentleman
like pat all the time talks about like i
feel like that's like your fondest
memories of life is your time in the
military and the camaraderie and you i
mean you've had friends come in here
yeah on the show and you know be a part
of this i mean what's your take on that
listen i mean he but he's at a different
level you got five you know
you're talking about he made it to the
pinnacle of experience and what you do
with the military ring you know to do
what he did but the main word you'll
hear from almost everybody in the
military is the sea word it's
camaraderie that camaraderie and by the
way here's the part
if you have thin skin you're not going
to make it in the military because the
jokes
if if 10 of the jokes were seen in the
public like you know you know military
they can't do vlogs because the youtube
channel would be shut down
they would offend everybody the jokes
are so direct and painful
that you're either going to be able to
handle or you're going to say i got to
transfer to a different unit so it
toughened you up you built a friends
relationships and you see anyone like
the other day one of my guys sent me a
message klingerman klingerman
this guy was funny he was a guy that
played football in ohio so we'd go to
bars in clarksville and we'd go drinking
here's how he was he would drink
one two three four five ten fifteen
twenty i mean he's drinking right when
he comes out if he didn't meet a girl
guess what he's doing getting in a fist
fight oh first of all that's automatic
because he was a linebacker this guy
almost made it to the next level if he
didn't meet a girl no joke his head is
going into a car's window
i mean we have to like not tonight
bam he would to entertain you guys was
that part of it
frustration it was almost like the movie
remember the program remember the movie
the program course well that one guy
would go in you know with his psychopath
he would paint his face with the blonde
but you know
crazy of a guy as he was everybody loved
them yeah that's crazy
you tell these stories and people are
like but pat that's not normal yeah
you're listening you buy your normal
this is our normal it is the reason that
i'm so freaking fascinated by this
because i played college football
tom zenner also played college football
there's a level of camaraderie and
manliness and like you know like but i
feel like in the military it's even more
enhanced like
the camaraderie in football is cool we
get along we'll be battling you know
punchy jump in the face and all that but
military it's life or death it's up
there it's not it's not life or death
meaning you're throwing a bomb yeah sure
damn sure it is very similar and i i
think i get along with a lot of pro
athletes like i have a lot of um like
ufc fighters that are my friends just
because the culture is the same it's put
in the hard work you know love your love
your can and then
have some fun it's pretty simple so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here